the whole slap thing
do you play it over in your head like
the subreddit film and go
i if i had it to do over again i would
have marched out
and thrown will smith right the [ __ ] out
of that building i mean
i don't know what i would have done if
the power were in my hands i
it was so it was so upsetting like and
people made fun of me for saying that it
was traumatizing but i don't think it
was traumatizing for me i think it was
traumatizing for all of us like it was
all
it was like it just was like chris
rock's my good friend like one of my
best friends and quest love is also one
of my best friends like
you know it's this is a small town and
the people who live in new york can stay
in new york like we're close and so to
see that happen
to see your friend get hit and then uh
and also will smith who i've loved and
we've all loved forever like i've i
don't remember a time i didn't think i
loved that guy and you know and i
haven't been around much violence
um
right you know i didn't grow up within
the home or anything so
it was upsetting for so many reasons and
it was saying to everyone everyone at
home who didn't even see what i saw
it was shocking and um it was a bummer
but you know for me i never i had no
i had no thoughts of like how it
affected me or my performance or
anything it was just upsetting as a
person
yeah
well i found it surreal i mean when he
got up and accepted the oscar go why is
this guy still sitting there he just
assaulted chris rock i i mean it seemed
abundantly clear to me what should be
done that this guy should have been
hauled out of the uh you know he just he
just basically attacked someone who
assaulted him
i just
yeah like i wasn't even i just thought
oh my god will smith
i mean and maybe this is bad this is
like you know i've i've i was in an
abusive relationship
um years ago but i'm like thinking
is this like
my i thought right away oh my god will
smith must be in so much pain have you
spoken to chris at all uh since the
oscars or have you just kind of said i'm
not gonna bother him oh no he's yeah
he's my good friend i saw him right
after
um and uh and yeah we've just texted a
little bit how do you advise him now
what do you do do you ignore it or do
you have to you have to come up with
material so you have to deal with it
like what what the [ __ ] do you do he
knows what he's doing
i have
like i just have a bad poker face and i
need to share what's on my mind in like
a compulsive way
um
but i think he's really smart
he's he's not really addressing it he's
a pro
sweetheart
you